pace of growth for let's say clinics uh
serving pediatric patients on on gender
issues in 15 last 15 years we had zero
now to over a 100 clinics clinics for
kids why the biggest single policy
Catalyst for this explosion is ObamaCare
insurance companies were mandated to to
provide coverage for what is deemed to
be medically necessary gender affirming
care and then an additional Amendment to
the Affordable Care Act was made gender
identity could no longer be a basis for
denial of
coverage um uh by private insurance
companies the idea that this is
connected to Obamacare is super
interesting and that there were then
incentives basically for all of these
clinics I mean he said we went from zero
of these clinics in 2010 to over a
hundred of these clinics